Tik Tok suspended the account then
reinstated it apologized and said it was
a human
[Music]
error okay so what about Tik Tok it's
parent company's bite dance which was
founded in 2012 and has had quite a few
different digital products from short
video websites uh to a News website in
2016 it released doing in China and a
year later it acquired another Shanghai
based video platform called musically
now musically had a very smart algorithm
the startup and that's why uh bite dance
acquired it so together with the
algorithm for musically it rolled out
Tik Tok worldwide so that was in 2017 so
the two apps have always been separate
products and uh here are some of the
major differences so doing is subject to
Chinese censorship and is only
accessible in mainland China whereas Tik
Tok has a different set of content
accessible worldwide users in China
can't access Tik Tok unless you use VPN
uh and vice versa and in doing you can
shop while you watch videos uh using
basically this idea of uh similar to
WeChat that you can combine e-commerce
with social media is replicated in doing
as well and you can't do that in Tik Tok
you just you only watch the
videos Tik tok's algorithms also seems
to much more promote short Snappy videos
one or two minute long and Tik Tok is
much more dominated by generation Zed
than doing is in China which is slightly
older generation so here's a screenshot
of what the doing interface looks like
when it comes to the e-commerce features
so you can watch a live stream from an
influencer and then immediately you can
follow through a link to something that
they're selling or wearing or whatever
it is and this takes you to taba which
is a kind of Amazon uh online platform
for selling things so basically it's
much more commercializable for
influencers and people who use it in
that way um so they are essentially two
different apps although they have very
similar ideas and since then both apps
have taken their respective markets by
storm in 2020 Tik Tok passed 2 billion
mobile downloads worldwide it's probably
the most Insurgent app and is the most
important out certain demographic as
well here in the west under
24s but as you know it's a controversial
one as well it's banned in India Trump
tried to ban It in America through an
executive order in 2020 and it's now
banned on government devices across the
five eyes Nations and Tik Tok CEO has
appeared before Congress to be grilled
on concerns surrounding the app
so what are these concerns well there
are a number of them the Crux of which
comes down to this question of whether
or not Tik Tok is fully independent of
the Chinese
government first and in my mind the most
easily refuted is a worry that it's some
kind of cops from the CCP it Taps into a
wider fear of civilizational decline
compared to the go- guessing Chinese
that I think you see quite a lot in
right-wing Media or as a former Google
employee said um this is a quote they
make their domestic version a spinach
version of Tik Tok while they ship the
Opium version to the rest of the world
now I'm going to leave aside how
offensive that opium comparison is
considering China's history for now but
I think from the talk so far you know I
hope I've explained why there is two
versions and the idea that actually that
there was they were two versions
completely designed in order to
brainwash the Western kids is simplistic
and false really um but I can see the
reason for this feere you know I don't
know if any of you do use Tik Tok but it
is incredibly addictive each video is a
short dopamin hit and before you have a
chance to switch off the app pops up
another video or you can cut short your
one and just go to the next one and
you're never really paying attention to
anything for more than a few minutes so
the definition of a Time sync which is
why full disclosure I don't use it
because I just don't need another reason
to be on my phone and I know myself I
know if I download it that's that's a
I'm I'm not going into bed before
midnight but I'm not sure it's it's just
not fundamentally true that doing is any
better for young people's minds and
attention spans than Tik Tok is you know
there hasn't been reliable and extensive
analysis of the content found on doing
to conclude that it really is a spinach
version although anecdotally social
media analysts obviously see this kind
of video they suggest that educational
content is given a bit more waiting on
doing than on Tik Tok and it is true
that on the Chinese version there's a
time limit for users under 14 so is it
some crafty Beijing scheme um well I
think the evidence for that isn't there
at all it assumes that bite dance is
working handin glove with the government
there's some kind of grand scheme to
roll out the two versions uh and as I
say that there is a reason why the two
versions exist and that's because of
censorship in China not because of some
kind of strategic promotion of rubbish
content outside of China what we also
know is that what happens inside China
is that the CCP is sexually prudish we
know that from the graphic scenes that
the fil film Bureau censors from
Hollywood films and it also believes in
the government giving moral leadership
to young people so I grew up in China I
was born there and I went to school
there those videos of you know children
being very very appreciative of their
teachers or having speed drawing that
kind of stuff you know really resonates
with my childhood because the whole
government and I would say society as a
whole really believe in kind of
cultivating the minds of young people in
a certain way which is not a kind of
liberal way that I think in in some
other places um as a whole Chinese
Society is more conservative than the
American it thinks that children are
more impressional and it wants to do
more about
it so bearing that in mind remember that
the people's daily tanked Qui sh shares
by just saying that the company was a
bad influence to to teenagers so if it
is the case that ding's content is more
sanitized um if it if someone did the
extensive analysis that is required and
found that then that's not surprising to
me because doing is inhabiting that
complicated economic environment in
China where it needs to not antagonize
the uh the Chinese government's sense of
social and moral values also its user
sense of Social and moral values whereas
Tik Tok driven purely by profit doesn't
need to follow these same kind of
spinach guidelines it's just a more L
say fair reflection of what Society is
interested in I guess in in this case
what users are interested in and I also
wouldn't be surprised if Tucker picked
the kind of videos that would strengthen
his
point so is that a problem I mean I'm
just not sure that I would want the
government to be dictating the content
of the social media apps that I use as I
say it strikes me of the country that I
grew up in and you know it's it's a kind
of molding of young minds that I just
don't think politicians should have that
power parents perhaps but not uh not
through government regulation which is
how it's achieved in China so I think
when people like taka Caren are
complaining about this difference we
should follow through the logical
conclusion of what they're saying which
is what that they want their kids to be
a bit more you know kind of educated and
uh trained up as the Chinese ones
are so I think that's one concern which
I think is easily refutable but there
are more tricky questions surrounding
Tik Tok even if the CCP is not running
the app if Tik Tok isn't as independent
from bite dance its mother company as it
claims and if bite dance wants to keep
the Chinese government suite at a
politically difficult time could Tik Tok
be compromised by Beijing and I think
that's a much more difficult question
now Tik Tok is at P at pains to stress
that bite dance is Incorporated in the
Cayman Islands that Tik tok's data is H
separately from doings and that staff in
China have no access to the data or say
or or or or any control over Tik tok's
algorithms but for them for the company
I think it's hard to prove a negative
it's hard to prove that the C party has
no influence over their operations or
certainly it's harder than to do that
than for some of their critics to list
concerning incidents and there have been
a few of those so in 2019 Tik Tok
suspended the account of 17-year-old for
fosa Asis who used the makeup tutorial
to criticize China's mass incarceration
of weer Muslims some of you might have
seen that it went totally viral Tik Tok
suspended the account then reinstated it
apologized and said it was a human error
and that's basically all that the
company said about it in the same year a
set of the platforms moderating
guidelines leaked which show that the
algorithm and moderators limited
politically controversial content some
users complained that when they searched
for Hong Kong on Tik Tok there weren't
many videos of the student protest that
had been happening that year which one
would have thought would have been uh
the most important event associated with
that with those key wordss at the time
given the student protests so had these
politically controversial videos been
censored well Tik Tok says that in its
early years it limited things
politically cont controversy across the
board just as a as a way to kind of
stabilize the platform increase users
and it wasn't country it wasn't country
specific and it also said that by about
2019 when this report came out those
guidelines had already been
retired and finally there's a concern
over data collection and sharing so as
with many social media apps Tik Tok
collects an extraordinary amount of data
on its users and often stuff that we as
users don't realize are being kept tabs
on it knows your location it knows how
long you're viewing a video it also
requests information about other apps
you're running on your phone there's a
debate among cyber security experts over
just how extraordinary some of these
asks are compared to other social media
platforms um kind of really spanning a
whole array of conclusions one from the
univers of Toronto last year concluded
that it wasn't any more thing more than
others whereas others say that um more
of Tik Tok data for example goes to
unknown third parties has been sold on
uh which is more concerning than other
platforms do so I'm not a cyber security
expert but these are the this is the
difference this debate going on at the
moment so clearly this is more of a
problem if this data is being accessed
by the Chinese government and there have
been incidents where the separation
between church and state that separation
between Tik Tok and bite dance has been
left less than ideal and certainly not
aligned with a full with a narrative of
full separation that Tik Tok insists it
has for example it's been reported that
leak recordings of internal Tik Tok
meetings quote Tik Tok staff as saying
everything is seen in China that user
data is quite easily accessed by bite
staff in
China and then after these and other
critical reports the journalist
concerned discovered that staff at bite
dance had tried to spy on them via Tik
Tok so bite dance staff was trying to
track down who the leaks inside the
company were and who they were speaking
who who was speaking to journalists they
access the location data gathered
through tracking down journalists Tik
Tok accounts private Tik Tok accounts uh
to determine who was meeting with bik
dance staff suspected to be leaking so
just tracking those no location data now
by the way Tik Tok uh B dance admits
this has happened it fired three staff
members uh while another one resigned
and triggered an internal investigation
into how this could have happened I
would say that this is incredibly
concerning B Dan sess is the actions of
a few Rogue agents but do we really know
that these people weren't simply
scapegoats that they weren't simply
carrying out practices signed off at a
much higher level I just don't think we
will know either way but I think uh it's
important to say though that this
episode was limited to bite Downs
wanting to limit negative coverage of
itself you know there is no evidence
that the CCP cared about who these
journalists were but it does suggest
that Tik Tok data isn't a separate an
inaccess to actors in China as it says
it is so what if the CCP request data
can bonss really say
no I don't know the question I don't
know the answer to that one as I say is
a constant cat and mouse game and I
think it would depend a lot on different
companies but I'm setting out the facts
in front of you now and I think it's for
you to decide whether or not uh you know
what the risk calculus is with using Tik
Tok for me I think I still need more
evidence that the party is
systematically controlling the company
as critics can suggest because companies
it goes back to my point about China not
being a monolith I believe that these
private companies have more say so have
more independent operations than is
often appreciated abroad but there is
obviously the context The Wider
political context of a tightening Leash
from the
state still that doesn't mean we sit on
our hands to continue watching this
video click the link in the top left or
in the description below or visit I.V
for more debates and talks from the
world's leading thinkers on today's
biggest ideas